Hey!
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser ... Ist so gemein, dass du immer auf Start drückst und dann sofort ... Du hast doch gerade gesagt, wenn du einfach deine Worte nicht beendest. Du hast sofort weißt, dass du jetzt anfangen und dann eine Anmoderation machen kannst. Du hast einen Anmoderationsvorteil, einen A-F. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge DPU das Podcast-Dufo-Podcast. DPU das Podcast-Dufo, wir sind die alle. Hey! Herzlich willkommen auch von mir, mein Name ist Stelbert Dietze, das, das ist Florian Will. Dankeschön, hallo. Wir begrüßen euch zur zweiten Folge des neuen Jahres 2017. Und heute geht es um ein Thema. Wir haben uns überlegt, mal wieder ein Thema zu machen, einfach weil wir das mal wollen. Um ein bisschen Struktur reinbringen. Um ein bisschen einen roten Faden reinzubringen. Wir wollen darüber reden, über Dinge, die einfach mal so sind, wie sie sind. Dinge, die anstehen. Dinge, die anstehen, Dinge, die einfach plötzlich mal so sind. Dinge, die gemacht werden müssen. Richtig. Und zwar, darüber haben wir immer, wir reden ja selten über unser wirkliches Privatleben. Und deswegen würde ich mir heute in meinen Körper einweisen. Schön, einmal, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Ich hatte vorgestern und da vor dem Tag ein Pochen in meinem Ohr plötzlich. Außerdem nichts,s ein Pochen in meinem Ohr, offensichtlich eine Art Tinnitus. Ja.
Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, was soll ich dagegen jetzt tun? Es war auch nicht mein Herzschlag, es war einfach unregelmäßig, was es wahnsinnig unerträglich macht.
Aber was soll man dagegen tun? Dafür gehe ich jetzt nicht zum Arzt, weil da ein bisschen was pocht. Nein, das ist mir zu unangenehm.
Vor allem, lass mich dir die biologische Erklärung dafür geben. Ich hab... Ach, Tarkan Baci, einer der talentiertesten Kommissar-Autoren Deutschlands. Es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass das dadurch entsteht, dass dein Gehör besteht ja aus ganz vielen kleinen Härchen. Und jedes Härchen hat einen eigenen Geruchssinn. Richtig, genau. Und das ist ja so, dass wenn du da irgendwie mit deinen Fingern reinfingerst oder irgendwie eines dieser Haare abbricht oder abfällt oder umknickt, dass dann dieser eine Ton konstant aktiv ist, so als würdest du den ständig hören und dein Gehirn irgendwann sagt, das kann nicht sein, dass dich die ganze Zeit und ihn irgendwann mutet und irgendwann
einfach sagt, du bist einfach raus.
Also höre ich diese Frequenz jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, das Haar ist immer noch kaputt,
aber der ist einfach raus. Du hast halt keine Ahnung,
hundert Härchen
pro Herz, was weiß ich,
Frequenz und irgendwann ist alles weg.
Mich widert dein Wissen
über Organe an, du bist auch,
du bist ein, erst mal
stehst du da nicht darauf, dass man deine
Augen anfasst, ich bin Typ
Vielen Dank. Mich widert dein Wissen über Organe an, du bist auch, du bist ein, erst mal stehst du da nicht darauf, dass man deine Augen anfasst, ich bin Typ, ich bin herzlich zu Menschen, ich fasse dir einen in Augen an. Du hast mir schnell gemerkt, bei jeder neuen Praktikantin, die reinkommt, erst mal direkt auf die Augen. Erst mal in die Augen fassen, erst mal in die Augen fassen. Schön erst mal die Augen. Du hast mir ganz schnell zu erkennen gegeben, dass du es nicht magst, wenn man an deinen Augen rumfummelt. Das stimmt. Weil du es nicht magst. Aber bei deinen Ohren war auch sowas. Du hast in New York nämlich dein erster Einkauf, war nicht irgendwie was zu trinken, Wasserflasche oder was für morgen, schön Toast, nein, du hast dir Ohrenstäbchen gekauft. Ja, ich bin Ohrenfetisch. 127 Ohrenstäbchen. Ich habe ein Fetisch, was Ohrenstäbchen angeht. Ich mag einfach, wenn so ein richtig dicker, schöner, harter Watteprängel so richtig wuchtig in meine Ohren reinwämst. Wirklich so in so einer Taktung, wie so ein Dampfermer, der da einfach so reinballert, einfach so unermüdlich. Das finde ich einfach geil. Es ist aber tatsächlich, hängt mit Gefahr zusammen, denn ich hatte schon oft Probleme mit Gehörgangsentzündung und Ansammlung von Ohrenschmalz und so, ist alles sehr eklat. Wenn du so ein Pochen gehabt hast, ein unregelmäßiges Pochen, wie so ein kleiner Zwerg, der drinnen mal gegen deine Wand klopft, wie so ein fieser Nachbar, der so meint Ey! Ich denke mir, manchmal haben wir so etwas gesehen, dass so ein Käfer, Leute haben Käfer in den Ohren und so was, weil die irgendwie draußen gecampt haben. Ganz wichtig, wenn einem so eine Fliege oder eine Biene ins Ohr fliegt, das passiert manchmal, dass einem so eine Fliege ins Ohr fliegt und dann nicht mehr rauskommt, Und das ist natürlich, das macht dich natürlich komplett wahnsinnig, weil du hast ein extrem lautes Surren im Ohr. Was man da machen soll, auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie mit einer Pinzette oder Ohrenstäbchen anfangen, rumzuwuhlen, weil dann würde man das Tier nur weiter reinschieben. Was man machen soll, ist Alkohol, Wodka, irgendwas Hochprozentiges ins Ohr kippen, damit das Flieger abgetötet wird und dann kann man sie rausnehmen.
Ich hab Angst, dass dann eine wilde Feier feiert.
Da sind dann noch mehr Leute, die kommen,
hier ist alles umsonst
und dann einfach ganz viel einlädt.
Aber Ohren ist echt der abgefahrenste,
mein Bruder hat eine gute Story,
aber die ist auch richtig gut, finde ich.
Ich habe keinen Grund, den Bruder zu beleidigen.
Jesus, unbedrängt, einfach den Bruder beleidigt.
Okay.
In Abwesenheit.
Aber es war tatsächlich so, der hat einmal was erlebt, das einzige Mal in seinem gesamten erbärmlichen Leben.
Komm ein bisschen runter, alles klar.
Okay.
Halt mich zurück, halt mich zurück.
In seinem nicht lebenswerten Leben hat er was erlebt, er ist um See spaziert.
Wow, Highlights. Jesus Christ. Wow, alles, wozu er zustande ist, um See spaziert. Und er hatte ja gerade eine Ohrenentzündung und hat da irgendwie mit seinen Ohrentropfen rumgemacht und so, hat irgendwie auf dem Spaziergang und dann ist jemand an ihm vorbeigelaufen und hat gesagt, aha, haben Sie Ohrenprobleme mit Ohrentropfen. Wichtig dabei ist, hat der Fremde ihm erklärt, wichtig dabei ist, dass man den Kopf ganz zur Seite neigt, also wirklich mit dem Ohr auf die Schulter drückt, ganz zur Seite neigt, damit die Ohrentropfen da drin bleiben. Und dann hat er ihm das so gezeigt und dann ist dieser fremde Mann noch den gesamten weiteren Weg so gelaufen. What? Fremde sind die besten. Und mein Bruder meinte, bis er ihn nicht mehr gesehen hat, hat er durchgehend, ist er so seitlich gelaufen. Also dieses, wenn sie Ohrentropfen machen müssen, müssen sie so machen und bleibt dann so und läuft dann so den Spägel entlang. Ich fand das unglaublich. Aber was machen denn Menschen, die auf beiden Seiten haben? Ja, das ist in der Tat sehr schwierig, weil da musst du halt immer so hin und her. Hin und her, aber wenn es da rauszulaufen droht,zulaufen droht, immer wieder schnell. Es ist dann immer so ein Kampf Zentripetal gegen Zentrifuge, Alter, dass du immer so vibrierst. Ich weiß noch, wie heute, ich bin zum Neomagazin gefahren und dann war ich mit dem Auto da, komischerweise. Und dann habe ich mit dem Auto geparkt, Handbremse gezogen und plötzlich hat es gejuckt und dann ist so ein Klumpen rausgeflogen, so ein Ohrenschmalzklumpen. Keine Ahnung warum. Rausgeschossen. Ja, rausgeschossen, so an die Scheibe, dann zerplatzt. Keine Ahnung, wie das möglich war. Mega widerlich, ich bin auch hygienisch eigentlich, ich wasche meine Ohren auch. Und das war mir sehr unangenehm. Und dann habe ich mich aber gefühlt, dann habe ich so am rechten Ohr rumgedaddelt, weil ich dachte, jetzt muss das ja ja auch rauskommen. Weil das ist ein Ungleichgewicht, mein Kopf ist rechts ein bisschen schwerer als links. Und dann bin ich so ein bisschen schief rumgelaufen. Ungleichgewicht im Körper macht mich wahnsinnig. Das Herz auf der linken Seite ist furchtbar. Oder zum Beispiel, wenn du halt nur halt manchmal den rechten Arm trainierst, also halt Muckibude klassisch rechter Arm, und dir dann denkst, jetzt ist ja alles Ungleichgewicht. Weil dann denkst du dir, okay, jetzt ist meine rechte Körperseite schwerer.
Vergiss doch Wörter, jetzt ist ja alles Ungleichgewicht.
Jetzt ist ja meine rechte Körperseite schwerer und dann laufe ich ja immer so leicht rechts geneigt.
Richtig.
Dann wird wieder mein linkes Bein stärker oder was auch immer.
Ja.
Wichtig ist, eine Harmonie herzustellen.
Meine Mutter ist ein Bein ein bisschen kürzer als das andere.
Macht mich Kirre. Wenn ich sie sehe, und man sieht es natürlich nicht, muss ich erst mal weinen. Schön, Ach, Asymmetrie, furchtbar. Hatten wir auch eine in der Klasse Pferde-Barbara, liebevoll genannt, bei der war auch ein Bein kürzer. Was ist bei euch falsch? Die fette Pferde-Barbara, Kotz Manuel. Der war auch ein Bein kürzer als das andere. Und das war für mich das Erste, was gesagt wurde. So, hallo, das ist die Barbara, und bei der ist das linke Bein kürzer als das rechte. Das müssen Sie nicht sagen. Und alle schauen sich so an, so. Frau Meier, das müssen Sie so nicht sagen. Ich bin Lehrerin, so einen Roast vorbereiten, wenn die Leute in die Klasse holen. So, wir haben einen Neun in der Klasse, das ist Daniel, der hat ein grösseres Ohr als das andere. Hat Spaß mit ihm. So die Gründe mitliefern, warum sie gemobbt werden kann. Aber was mich als Kind immer fertig gemacht hat, weil die hatte dann auch besondere Schuhe, also einen besonderen Schuh, der halt höher war. Also zwei besondere Schuhe. Oh, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Was macht einen Schuh besonders? Ist ein Schuh besonders, wenn er ungleich ist zu dem anderen Schuh oder in Abgrenzung zu allen anderen Schuhen. In meinem Kopf war er gerade besonders zum anderen
Schuh, weil dann sind beide besonders,
weil es gibt ja nur zwei.
Und die hatte andere Schuhe und mich als Kind hat es
immer fertig gemacht, weil ich nicht wusste
so, ab welchem
Gleichgewicht man einen neuen Schuh braucht.
Weil ich glaube, wenn man jedes Bein eines
jeden Menschen messen würde, würde man rausfinden,
immer ein bisschen anders.
Wo ist dann der Punkt? Ich dachte mir, ja Moment mal, vielleicht ist mein Bein auch so vier Millimeter länger, aber ab wann brauche ich diesen Schuh? Also was ist der Punkt, wo man sagt, nee, ab jetzt neuer Schuh, ab jetzt definitiv neuer Schuh oder auch Arme und ich dann, ich habe wirklich bestimmt ein Jahr meines Lebens, immer geht, fuck, was ist, wenn meine Arme nicht gleich lang sind oder wenn meine Schulter nicht und immer was ist. Jeder von uns hat eine chronische Krankheit, locker, sowas wie leichte Form von Asthma, leichte Form von Diabetes, hat jeder. Und ich denke mir immer, ab welchem Moment liegt es nur daran, dass man einmal nicht beim Arzt war oder so, sonst hätte man jetzt ein verschreibungsfähiges Medikament, was man ab jetzt so nimmt halt abends. Ich kann ja sowieso fragen, ist die Krankheit immer so ein binäres Ding, entweder du bist krank oder nicht, oder ist jeder Mensch bei jeder Krankheit auf so einer Skala nur halt noch nicht weit genug geschritten.
Eben, und in unserem System, das System, da ist es halt nun mal so, dass es nur nur Einsen gibt, aber es gibt natürlich viele.
Aber zum Thema Harmonie und gleich grosse Körperteile, sehr interessant fand ich auch, ich habe mal Zwillinge kennengelernt, weibliche Zwillinge, und dann war es so, dass irgendwann die eine von den beiden Zwillingen meinte, sie sei lesbisch und dann die andere Schwester ganz aufgelöst so, ja Moment, ja dann bin ich ja auch lesbisch, so weil sie dachte so, wir sind ja gleich und alles und dann so völlig so, so von außen kam diese sexuelle Identität plötzlich an sie ran, so Moment, dann muss ich jetzt auch lesbisch sein, so dieses konnte sie überhaupt nicht erfassen, dass sie auch anders sein kann. Das fand ich so lustig. Einfach dieses so, ja, ich hab heute Mittag Chicken Nuggets gegessen. Ja, dann muss ich jetzt auch, hab ich jetzt auch Chicken Nuggets gegessen. Hör auf, ich nehm zu! In so einem konstanten, oh nein, der andere macht was für einen selber. Also ganz furchtbar. Ich wollte heute Abend den La La Land, den habe ich schon gesehen. Nein!
Scheiße.
Aber das ist interessant, weil es bis jetzt heute, also ich weiß nicht, aber ich glaube, es ist bis heute noch nicht ganz geklärt, woher Homosexualität eigentlich kommt und ob das nicht auch so ein bisschen was mit der DNA zu tun hat, zum Bruchteil zumindest. Und das finde ich schon spannend. Also auch das vielleicht ...
Ja, es gibt doch diese Wachowski-Ehemalsbrüder.
Wachowski-Geschwistern wurden und jetzt die Wackowski-Schwestern sind. Es sind beides jetzt zu Frauen geworden. Aber Stück für Stück, ne? Ja, und immer wurden ihre Filme schlechter. Also, je mehr, je mehr... Was sagt uns das über Frauen aus? Je mehr sie zu wider der Natur gehandelt haben, desto furchtbarer wurden die Filme. Naja, Moment, das könnte aber auch so dieser David-Lynch-Ding sein, wo du ja mal die interessante David-Lynch-Anekdote erzählt hast, dass David Lynch beim Therapeuten war und ihm seine Leiden geklagt hat, Depression oder Schizophrenie oder irgendwas. Und dann der Therapeut hat gesagt, ja, kein Problem, können wir alles machen. Und dann hat David Lynch gefragt, ja, Moment mal, aber wenn ich dann gesund bin, werden dann meine Filme schlechter. Der Therapeut meinte, das kann gut sein, weil die natürlich auch aus einer gewissen inneren Zerrissenheit und Unbequemheit kommen und dann meinte David Lynch ja dann nicht. Dann mache ich keine Therapie. Dann hat er sein eigenes Leid oder sein eigenes Schicksal vorgezogen seinem kreativen Abfall und so kann es ja tatsächlich Genau wie Chevy Chase einen morgen mal aufgewacht ist und nicht mehr lustig war. Und das ist das Ende der Story. Das kann jedem von uns passieren. Ja, ist auch bestimmt bei einem von uns passiert, aber wir sind halt in diesem komischen Kosmos gefangen, wo das eigentlich auch egal ist. Ja, wo man einfach ab alle fünf Minuten der Titzler sagen muss und die Leute feiert. Lachen es auch. Wir sind jetzt mittlerweile in so einem System gefangen, so Leute gehen davon aus, dass das, was man sagt, gerade lustig ist, auch wenn es ernst gemeint ist. Ja, das stimmt. Na, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, wir müssen noch ein bisschen was dafür tun. Aber wie gesagt, bei diesem Ohrenklopfen dachte ich kurz so, ja, das ist halt jetzt das, was ich habe. So, das ist jetzt, wenn ich in Interviews mal irgendwas sage, dann ist das, was ich erwähne. Das ist so mein Ding jetzt einfach. So, wenn ich mit Freunden spreche, das ist das Ding, was ich jetzt habe. Das gehört jetzt zu mir. Ich habe jetzt Ohrenklopfen, komischerweise. Bist du eigentlich wehleidig? Nee, ich habe nur wahnsinnig Angst vor Dingen. Okay, wow, ich habe auch eine andere Frage geantwortet. Nee, ich habe Angst, dass ich, ich habe Angst vor Krankheiten, Wahnsinnige, so, weil das ist ja furchtbar, das ist das Schlimmste, was du haben kannst, so. Aber konkrete Krankheiten, für wen du Angst hast? Ja, Krankheiten, ich habe extreme Angst vor dem Schlaganfall, glaube ich. Manchmal liege ich so rum in meinem Bett und denke mir so, boah, wäre echt schon scheiße, wenn du jetzt einen Schlaganfall hätte. Das denke ich mir ziemlich häufig. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich nicht wehleidig, grossartig, nee. Ich frage auch oft einfach ganz unverhohlen nach, was das jetzt bedeutet, weil für Krankheiten kann man ja oft einfach nichts. Ja, stimmt schon. Zum Beispiel, was man auch kennt vielleicht, wenn man so ganz weit den Mund aufmacht oder gähnt, dann so ein ganz beissender, starker Schmerz in den Kinn und der ist so hart, der tut so weh. Und zwar sind das die Muskeln, die sich an dem Kieferkinn, genau, genau. Die Kiefern, so ein bisschen verschieben gefühlt und dann reicht aber, wenn man den Daumen so ein bisschen, das wieder massiert. Ja, oder das andere. Einfach gar nichts mal. Das denke ich mir auch immer so, und ich denke mir, teilweise, wenn ich das habe, denke ich mir, dieser Schmerz ist so intensiv und so stark, aber wenn ich jetzt jemandem sage, weil dann, dann können, ja, okay. Ich kenne das nicht. Keine Ahnung, wenn man irgendwie zu viert draußen steht und es ist kalt, dann kann man sagen, oh, es ist kalt und dann so, ja, es ist richtig kalt, so, dann hat das einen Sinn, das zu teilen. Aber wenn man jetzt alleine irgendwie so Schmerz im Kinn hat, so, wir haben Schmerz im Kinn, ja. Das hatte ich lange mit Hirnfrost, wenn man Slush-Eis gegessen hat. Oh ja. Ich als großer Slush-Eis-Verfechter und Fan habe das oft gehabt, dass ich mich da reingesetzt habe und das verschlungen habe und dann habe ich halt ganz oft Schmerzen in den Stirn gehabt und wusste nicht, was es ist und Das ist der unerträglichste Schmerz und das weiß ich auch noch nicht ganz, was es ist.
Aber da weiss man auch, dass der Schmerz bald wieder vorbei ist.
Das ist so ein Schmerz, wo man mittlerweile gelernt hat, der ist gleich wieder vorbei und das macht den eigentlich okay.
Du weisst, es ist gleich wieder weg.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber auch da habe ich immer Angst gehabt zu sagen, dass ich da gerade Schmerzen habe, weil das so unnatürlich war, weil alle gerade Eis essen und ich der Einzige bin, der
ganz, ganz
zerdeppert guckt.
Ich dachte mir auch zum Beispiel so tasern.
Da heißt es ja so tasern, wenn Leute sich mal so aus Spaß
als Selbstexperiment tasern lassen,
heißt es, das ist der schlimmste Schmerz
der Welt, weil irgendwie gleichzeitig
alle Nerven mit Strom versorgt werden
und alle Nerven,
Neuronen feuern hier, fuck, hier ist gerade Guantanamo und du hast einen brutalen Schmerz, aber nur kurz und dann ist er gleich wieder vorbei und ganz weg, weil sobald der Strom aufhört zu fliessen, ist der Schmerz auch direkt weg. Das heißt, du hast den schlimmsten Schmerz, den du jemals spüren wirst, aber nur kurz. Und da belege ich mir manchmal, ob das nicht eine interessante Erfahrung ist, weil du weißt, alles was danach kommt, also wenn du jetzt ein Kind kriegst oder dir jemand ein Bein abschneidet, du weißt, es ist nicht so schlimm wie damals. Es sei denn, du trittst nicht aus dem Taser-Club aus, weil dann wirst du noch ein paar Mal erleben. Vielleicht ist es auch andersrum, vielleicht wird man süchtig danach und plötzlich reicht einem der andere Schmerz nicht mehr, weil man immer zu dem höheren Schmerz hin strebt. Hast du Angst davor, süchtig zu werden von irgendwas? Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Echt? Ich bin sehr suchtanfällig, ja. Ich war sehr lange süchtig nach WoW, Computer, Internetsüchtig. Ich würde mich immer noch als süchtig nach Essen bezeichnen, so dumm das klingt, aber es ist oft einfach übernehmend, überhandnehmend in meiner Gedankenwelt.
Ja, das fällt mir oft auf.
Es sind ein grosser
Teil, wenn man es am Tag mit
Plurrentin verbringt, sind es 80% Gespräche
über Essen. Das ist schon
auffällig, ja.
Aber es ist auch so, dass es bei mir so ist,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt,
aber ich denke oft so, welche
Mahlzeiten habe ich noch vor mir heute. Wenn ich jetzt nach Hause gehe, gleich, jetzt gleich, dann weiß ich nach, ah, ich habe noch das Abendessen, dann mache ich mir vielleicht irgendwie, was weiß ich, irgendwie so eine Toreu-Torte warm oder sowas, so weiß ich, habe ich noch, noch steht jetzt zwischen mir und dem Schlafengehen, sobald ich diese Toreu-Torte mir in mein Mundloch geschoben habe, dann denke ich mir, oh, ich habe nichts mehr zwischen jetzt und Bett gehen und dann wäre wäre ich nervös. Wenn ich weiß, wenn ich jetzt Hunger kriege, habe ich verloren. Ich glaube, ich habe extreme Angst davor, hungrig ins Bett zu gehen. Ja, weil ich da nicht schlafen kann. Ich muss ein paar Sachen noch aufräumen, wie du gerade gesagt hast. Erstmal, ist Essen eines der Dinge, von denen ich mir wünschte, ich müsste sie nicht mehr tun. Das ist sowas, ich will nicht mehr essen müssen. Das sind das, auf Toilette gehen und generell einschlafen. Auf Toilette gehen ist doch super. Nee, ich hasse Dinge, die ich machen muss, weil ich dazu gezwungen werde, weil ich ein Mensch bin. So, essen zu wollen, das Bedürfnis zu haben, zu essen, aufs Tor zu gehen oder auch die Zeit, die ich mit dem Einschlafen verbringe, sind Zeiten, ich hoffe, dass es in der Zukunft irgendwann mal so ein Mittel gibt, wo man sich spritzt und schläft ein. Ja, auf Einschlafen kann ich auch verzichten, aber auf Klo gehen ist doch super. Finde ich furchtbar. Das ist doch total gut. Es nervt, es nimmt Zeit weg. Es ist genau wie warten. Ja, aber es ist ein Moment für dich, dass du einfach mal irgendwie kurz gehen kannst, sich nicht ausklingen kannst, irgendwie schaust du auf Instagram irgendwie Leute an und dann so, das ist halt so ein Moment. Es ist Zeitverschwendung meiner Meinung nach. Nee, aber du brauchst solche kleinen Rente für dich. Der Aufsteht geht es für den Tag nicht. Doch, ein bisschen schon. Ich habe mich auch selber konditioniert in der Schule, musste ich nie auf Toilette gehen. Ich musste es einfach nicht, ich musste nie in der Schule auf Toilette gehen. Ich musste immer, ich habe einen sehr geregelten Toilettengang. Wir sind heute sehr intim, das ist halt leider immer so, aber ihr müsst jetzt durch mit uns. Aber mir ist das Gegenteil, ich muss sehr oft aufs Klo und teilweise auch drei, vier Mal hintereinander. So, ich war und setze mich hin und denke, ich muss nochmal und dann immer wieder. Ich glaube, ich bin komplett ruiniert innerlich. Ich bin komplett kaputt. Mein Magen ist komplett hinüber und meine Blase ist auch komplett hinüber. Ich glaube, meine Blase ist so ein bisschen wie so ein schlecht erzogenes Kind, weil ich glaube mittlerweile, dass gerade bei mir sich der Harndrang, also das Bedürfnis aufs Klo zu gehen und die tatsächliche Füllung der Blase komplett entkoppelt hat. Das ist nicht so ein Altersding, dass eine Blase gealtert ist? Auf jeden Fall, dass sie nichts mehr miteinander zu tun haben. Wie halt keine Ahnung, bei Kindern, wo zum Beispiel das Quengelbedürfnis nach Süßigkeiten nichts mit deren Hunger zu tun hat, zum Beispiel, dass das nicht gekoppelt ist und dass sie dann auch die Süßigkeiten nicht zufrieden stellen. So ist es bei mir auch. Ich muss teilweise aufs Klo, obwohl meine Blase gar nicht voll ist und mir denke, ihr könnt jetzt noch längere Zeit nicht aufs Klo gehen. Ich glaube, das hat sich komplett entkoppelt, weil ich einfach meine Blase schlecht erzogen habe, weil ich zu schnell nachgegangen habe, weil immer wenn ich aufs Klo muss, gehe ich sofort. Und dass sie dann irgendwann frech wird. Ja, ich habe das manchmal so psychosomatisch, dass man das Gefühl hat, man muss jetzt aufs Klo. Ich habe Angst davor, im Kino aufs Klo zu müssen. Oh ja. Und deswegen habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, ich muss aufs Klo, weiß aber ich muss gar nicht, weiß aber wiederum, dass das Gefühl das gleiche ist. Von daher, das ist ein Problem. Star Wars Episode 3, die Unterhaltung kurz bevor Order 66, als Padme und Obi-Wan in ihrem Apartment sind und so diskutieren, so, oh, was ist mit Anakin und Obi-Wan es nicht übers Herz bringt, ihr zu sagen, dass Anakin jetzt böse ist, der Brunnen. Da steht mitten in dem Fucking-Raum so ein kleiner Brunnen, so ein kleiner phallusartiger Stängel, wo oben so Wasser rauskommt und ich saß im Kino, habe mir das erste Mal angeguckt und musste Mörder aufs Klo.
Und das die ganze Zeit, das hat mir echt den Rest gegeben, bin ich dann aufs Klo gegangen und dann kam ich wieder und dachte mir, hä, wer ist denn der schwarze Typ mit dem Umhang? So, völlig verwirrend, bis heute nicht verstanden, was da passiert ist. Birdman war bei mir so extrem krass, so kurz bevor da diese ganze Surrealismus-Sache losging, wo man wirklich den Birdman gesehen hat, im Hintergrund und so, musste ich dermaßen aufs Klo und der Film ging noch lang. Und dann war die letzte Vorstellung, nein, das ist nicht das Ende, nein, da sind die noch im Krankenhaus und dann noch ein spannendes Gespräch, was achtzehn Minuten dauert. Wow, das war furchtbar, das ist schlimm, aber ich habe es durchgehalten. Ich war mit einem Freund im Kino, mit dem war ich danach nie wieder im Kino, der ist mit in der Vorstellung aufs Klo gegangen, kam zurück, setzte sich neben mich und fragte mich, was habe ich verpasst. Ja, fuck. Und ich dachte mir, Alter, hast du eigentlich einen Schaden? Ja. Glaubst du, erstens glaubst du nicht, ich kann mich daran erinnern, was in den letzten fünf Minuten passiert ist. Ja. Und erzähl dir das jetzt, weil in der Zeit, in der ich dir das erzähle, das ist wie diese Schildkröte und Achilles. In der Zeit, in der ich dir das jetzt erzähle, nimm es einfach so hin. In der Zeit, in der ich dir das jetzt erzähle, ist ja wieder neue Handlungen passiert, die wir beide nicht wissen. Dann muss ich den neben mir fragen, was es in der Zeit passiert. Und irgendwann das gesamte Kino ist nur noch damit beschäftigt, sich irgendwie den Blog zu erzählen. Ganz kurz anhalten, bitte. Einmal ganz kurz Stopp. Machen Sie mal kurz Anstopp. Filmstrich! Ah Lieblingsanekdote. Auch noch eine lustige Geschichte. Das richtige Wort zu kennen, das Selbstbewusstsein zu haben, das zu sagen. Ey, ich war da nicht mit einem Kumpel ins Kino. Ey, der hat sich als der beste Kumpel der Welt rausgestellt. Sorry, muss ich mal so sagen. Weil wir haben zusammen einen Film geguckt. Nocturnal Animals von Tom Ford, Megafilm, könnt ihr euch gerne mal angucken.
Echt? Ich habe so gemischte Sachen drüber gehört. Superfilm, ich finde den mega gut, überragender Film. So, und dann waren wir in einem Kino und dann waren auch nicht so viele Leute da, ich dachte, das war auch eine Nachtvorstellung so, und dann dachte ich, da bin ich gern drin, weil wenige Leute da sind, die quatschen können potenziell. Und dann waren hinter uns, verstehe ich auch nicht, warum die in solchen Filmen gehen, waren dann so fünf jüngere Mädchen, die dann einfach sich hinter uns gesetzt haben genau und offensichtlich in den Filmen. Wegen Ryan Gosling, wegen Jake Gyllenhaal offensichtlich. Die wollten einfach abends irgendwo hin betrunken und haben sich halt einen Film ausgesucht, der gerade jetzt gerade läuft. Ist der falsche Film dafür, weil er beginnt mit so nackten, dicken Frauen und so, der halt dazu anregt, solche Leute einfach komplett in Ekstase bringen zu lassen. Weil das ist das Lustigste, was sie sich gerade vorstellen können, dass da dicke, nackte Frauen gerade rum und die haben ununterbrochen die ersten fünf Minuten durchgeschrien. Also das war nicht mehr mal reden, das war ein Schreien und so. Und ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich traue mich dann nicht, was zu sagen. Und der Kumpel hat aber neben, ich habe ihn so anguckt und er hat genau das gleiche Gesicht gezeigt wie ich, und hat dann gesagt, er hat sich umgedreht, hat einen ganz ruhigen Ton angeschlagen und die perfekten Worte gefunden. Er hat gesagt, ich weiß zwar nicht, warum ihr gerade hier seid, aber bitte hört einfach auf zu reden, denn wir wollen diesen Film gucken, ich weiß nicht, was ihr wollt, aber wir wollen den Film gucken. Und er hat diese Drogen am Anfang ausgesprochen, aber dann noch so einen freundlichen Touch gefunden. Das war perfekt, die waren ruhig, die ganzen Filme, keine Ahnung, wie das möglich war, aber er hat, das finde ich so beeindruckend, jeder braucht so einen Menschen, jeder braucht einen Menschen, der einem hilft bei sowas, der einfach Dinge sagt, die einem dann helfen in der Situation und er hat die perfekte Anzahl der Wörter gefunden, schön prägnant, aber auch mit so einer kleinen Beleidigung, die so ein bisschen wow auslöst am Anfang. Ich weiß zwar nicht, warum ihr hier seid, aber bitte seid doch einfach leise, wir wollen den Film gucken. Ja, das war sehr gut. Toller Film, guck den dir an. Ja, ich bin auch unentschlossen, aber ich gucke mal rein, vielleicht. Woher kommt Amy Adams eigentlich? Plötzlich ist sie in jedem Film dabei. So wie, erst mal, wie geht das überhaupt? Arrival und der kam jetzt genau zur gleichen Zeit raus. Anna war offensichtlich wesentlich länger in der Postproduktion und erst mal woher kommt die, plötzlich ist die dabei einfach in jedem Film. Ich habe die ja damals noch in The Office gesehen, The Office US. Stimmt. Da hat sie Jims Freundin für eine Folge gespielt oder sein Date oder sowas und da dachte ich mir schon, echt gute Schauspielerin, also vielleicht ist es auch irgendwie, rekonstruiere ich das jetzt, aber da dachte ich mir schon, okay krass, die fällt da raus aus diesem Cast, weil die sehr gut ist und dann später ich habe sie dann bei american hustle das nächste mal gesehen glaube ich da war es dann aber ich glaube die hatte davor auch schon noch eine große rolle oder so und dann auch kann gut sein auch eine serie und er weiß nicht genau aber auf jeden fall toll ja und hier auch dingsbury larson ist jetzt für mich die nächste amy adams und auch Auch richtig gut, auch in Room. Ja, super gut. Room habe ich leider nicht gesehen, hol dir nach. Room habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Auf jeden Fall, die musst du richtig sehen, die musst du sehen, ist gut. Aber es ist mittlerweile auch so, dass die Oscar, die Nominierung kam ja jetzt raus, dass es mittlerweile nur noch, weißt du nicht, so fünf Filme ausgewählt werden. So, und diese fünf Filme kriegen jetzt alle Oscars. Ja. So, die kriegen jetzt alle Nominierungen. Irgendominierungen. War das immer schon so? Oder ist es
jetzt so, weil ich mich dafür interessiere und das darauf achte?
Vielleicht ist dieses Jahr schon
ein bisschen mehr Verdichter der,
das stimmt schon, ja. Aber das sind so Dinge, die einfach mal anfallen.
Auch ins Kino gehen und dann mal
man muss auch mal Arschloch sein
zwischendurch. Auf jeden Fall.
Gelenkschmerzen,
ich habe starke Schmerzen in meinem linken
Unterarmgelenk. Ich glaube, weil wir haben sehr kantige Tische, bei uns sehr kantig, sehr harte Kanten, hartkantig, und dann habe ich mich so draufgestützt und mit meinem Unter, so des Schienenbein des Unterarms, sagen wir jetzt mal, mein Unterarm, Knochen, habe mich da so draufgestützt und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt, dass das richtig fucking wehtut und ich glaube, ich habe da einfach so Nerven abgegeben, mir schlafen auch sehr oft Dinge ein. Alles an mir schläft ein, nur ich selber nicht. Ich selber habe immer grosse Einschlafschwierigkeiten, aber ich glaube, mein Arm kriegt pro Tag mehr Schlaf als ich selber. Mir stellen nicht Sachen einschlafen. Aber auch, weil du das abklemmst dann aus Versehen oder weil du einfach... Wahrscheinlich, ich will mir das gar nicht vorstellen, was in meinem Arm passiert, wenn ich einschlafe, weil da muss ja irgendwelche Nerven, was, wo sind denn, ist Nerven dasselbe wie eine Ader? Ich glaube, dass du, ach, ist es nicht mehr Blut so, dass wenn du Adern abklemmst, dass die nicht mehr richtig versorgt werden mit Blut? Aber Nerven ist doch nicht dasselbe wie, ja, aber einschlafen hat doch was mit, dann sind die Nerven mit Blut unterversorgt, ach, was, was ich denn, ich will mir das gar nicht vorstellen, weil das ist auch ekelhaft so, ach, als Arzt musst du doch auch durch die Welt, paranoid durch die Welt gehen, so, du weißt ja genau, was gerade passiert in deinem Körper, wenn was Furchtbares passiert. Oder du gehst halt noch analytisch daran. Aber vielleicht weißt du auch, was so ein Körper aushält. Also dass du denkst, ich habe schon so viele Dinge, die in der Intensivstation, irgendwie Unfall, irgendwie kriegt so ein Pferd ins Gesicht, irgendwie kriegt so eine Absperrung, irgendwie direkt durchs Gehirn gebohrt, ja, konnten wir retten, kein Stress. Der muss sich auch denken, ja gut, als Mensch bist du unbesiegbar. Vier Schüsse irgendwie in die Brustgegend, ja, konnten wir noch retten. Das Flugzeugflügel-Syndrom, als ich mal gesehen habe in der Doku, wie viel das eigentlich aushält, das ist einfach so, es könnte dir zuwinken, das Flugzeug, einfach mal so ganz hoch, könnte das Flügel, um ganz runter 90 Grad, scheiß doch drauf, egal. Was ist da jetzt die Botschaft? Mein Gott, jede Turbulenzen haltet. Hab Vertrauen in das hält schon was aus du kannst in die krasseste Windbüge kommen, Flurantin mach dir keine Gedanken, du brauchst dir keinen Kopf machen, wenn du demnächst mal wieder fliegst wenn du kannst in Turbulenzen kommen die hat die Nordsee noch nicht gesehen, so Winde können da kommen, das ist kein Problem alles klar klar, er hat während der ganzen Zeit seine Flügel ausgebreitet, die ganze Zeit. Er hat um sich geschwäht. Ein bisschen abgehoben, auch ein bisschen. Oh! Cool. Ja, aber ich weiß auch nicht, so einschlafen ist, aber ist es bei dir beim richtigen Einschlafen? Nicht beim Fake-Einschlafen. Man weiss doch, warum man nicht einschläft. Also ich weiss immer, okay, gerade geht mir was im Kopf umher, worüber ich nachdenke, was mich zu sehr wach hält zum Beispiel. Grübeln ist eine Sache, du bist bestimmt auch ein Grübeler, wir sind Grübeler, wir beginnen eine Rehabilitete durch die Welt, wir analysieren die Welt. So, und dann grübelst du nach und denkst nach und dann weisst du, okay, du bist gerade noch zu wach dabei, Dinge zu analysieren, um jetzt einzulaffen zu können. Ja, oder halt Katzenurin. Bei mir auch recht oft einfach fucking Katzenurin, weil meine Katze einfach komplett explodiert ist und alles vollgerödelt hat mit Katzenurin. Das ist schrecklich, das ist einfach furchtbar. Ich habe in der letzten Zeit eine Nacht in Katzenurin, dann eine Nacht in einer gerade gewaschenen, feuchten Bettdecke. Es ist einfach so manche Grenzsituationen. Eine Nacht in einem Büro, frag nicht weiter nach. Wo du ins Bett gehst und denkst, okay, jetzt ist es ein Uhr, jetzt würde ich gerne ins Bett gehen, merkst, oh, meine Katze hat ins Bett gepinkelt, dann wäschst du deine Bettwäsche, dann ist es drei Uhr nachts, dann hängst du dir noch zwei Stunden über die Heizung, dann ist es fünf Uhr nachts, sie ist immer noch feucht und denkst dir, ja ja, ich leg mich jetzt unter eine feuchte Bettdecke. Und dann legst du dich unter eine feuchte Bettdecke und denkst dir, ja, Fische schlafen jeden Tag so, das muss schon hinhauen.
Aber denkst du ja nicht so? Und ich konnte dann auch schlafen noch eine Zeit lang, aber...
Du bezahlst ja auch für dein Zuhause hier in Köln.
Du bezahlst ja dafür.
Du hast es erworben, das ist dein Zuhause.
Denkst du manchmal nicht, das, was du gerade dein Zuhause nennst, ist möglicherweise gerade nicht mehr der beste Ort, um die Nacht in Köln zu verbringen? Also es gibt ja auch andere Möglichkeiten. Du hast Geld zum Beispiel. Geld oma. Du könntest in ein Hotel gehen zum Beispiel. Du könntest sagen, du hast Fans in Köln. Du könntest sagen, du, also, kommt man doch nicht ins Grübeln, dass man nicht mehr das beste Leben führt, was man eigentlich führen könnte gerade?
Ich würde eigentlich schon mal gerne in ein Hotel, da habe ich noch nie gemacht, in ein Hotel gegangen und gesagt, ich hätte jetzt für die Nacht jetzt gerne ein Zimmer.
Klar, das ist schon cool.
Im Hotel zu wohnen, glaube ich, würde ich auch machen, wenn ich genug Geld hätte, würde ich im Hotel wohnen.
Das stimmt eigentlich schon.
Das ist das beste Gefühl.
Was machst du denn mit deinem Star-Ross-Schlafanzug, mit deinem Bruce-It-Ball, mit deinen ganzen Büchern, mit deinen Comicsammeln, Lucky Luke-Comics?
Alter, das ist 2017, das ganze Zeug,ug kannst du haben, das könnt ihr alle haben draußen. Wohl den Laserschwert könnt ihr haben, wohl den Lego-LTS-Team könnt ihr haben. Mach du mal den Flohmarkt, mach du mal den grossen Stefan-Tietze-Fehlkauf-Flohmarkt. Können wir gerne machen. Ja, den FF, dann baust du schön bei dir im Hof die Matte auf. Den Fehlfloh. Können wir gerne machen. Dann verkaufst du dein ganzes Zeug, das du fälschlicherweise gekauft hast. Die Leute kämen strömend, da könnten wir uns eine ganze Live-Tour mitfinanzieren. Es ist 2017, es ist vorbei, ich bin da jetzt rausgewachsen. Jetzt erzähl mal ein bisschen was über dein neues Image. Du hast schon gesagt, du hast angekündigt, du willst dir ein neues Image bauen, du willst weg vom Fehlkommensteffen. Wenn ich mit meinem Studium vorbei bin, bin ich ein gelernter Akademiker. Ich kann mir dann nicht mehr erlauben, über Fehlkäufe Witze zu machen oder über neues Kratzeisunglück in der Post. Dann fange ich an, die gesellschaftlich relevanten Themen auseinanderzunehmen, Feinheit zu filetieren und zu pflücken. Und dann wird mal ein bisschen Fortschritt gemacht, hier im Podcast so vor auch. Dann wird man auch, dann haben wir ein Impositionsstück, haben wir auch mal eine Botschaft. Dann heißt es, okay, der Mensch strebt nach Anerkennung. Solche kleinen Botschaften werden mal hervorgepflückt. Und das ist der neue Stefan, der Comedy macht, der nicht mehr nur zu Hause sitzt und lernt, sondern schreibt dann nochmal einen Film. Er schreibt mal eine Serie. Oder der geht auf die Bühne, nimmt ins Boeing und spielt fünf Minuten Sets. Im März wolltest du dein Set machen. Ab März. Es ändert sich nicht das Datum, es ändert sich nur die Präposition. Nach März. Ist unendlich, ist das auch inbegriffen in der Menge? Nach März? Irgendwann nach März. Irgendwann, ja, ja, okay. Wir werden sehen. Nee, ich bin schon ganz zuversichtlich. Mich hat jemand angeschrieben und gefragt, ob ich nicht Bock hätte. Er hätte zufällig einen Laden und ob ich nicht Lust hätte, mal Stand-up zu machen, war ich jetzt ja mal erwähnt.
Ich hätte mal aushelfen können.
Ich habe gesagt, ja klar kann ich machen, jetzt hat er gefühlt eine Tour geplant und danach hat er gesagt, ja das ist dann wöchentlich in Chemnitz und wir machen dann erst, erst spielst du, dann spiel ich und danach machen wir ein bisschen Impro mit dem Publikum, ich bin da ziemlich gut drin, alles klar, ciao. Und ich habe es nicht mehr zurückgeschrieben, aber ich glaube, ich bin jetzt in einem Vertrag gefangen, wo ich jede Woche nach Chemnitz muss und mit ihm irgendwie eine Tour spielen muss.
Okay.
Nicht schlecht. Auch das ist so ein Ding, was jetzt angefallen ist. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ja, auch ich bin sehr gespannt. Die Stefan und Paul Show. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann sie losgeht, aber ich bin gespannt. Aber auch in so eine Show zu kommen mit einer Person, mit der man sich noch nie unterhalten hat und plötzlich auf der Bühne steht und hier ist Stefan und Paul. Ping, ping, pong, das dynamische Duo, hallo, typisch Paul, geil. Könntest du mit einem Fremden, ja, ja, habe ich schon ein paar Mal, du nickst schon seit zehn Minuten, du weißt schon, du warst kaum, auf jeden Fall, doch, aber auch das war jetzt so ein Ding, was anfällt, es sind manchmal so Dinge, musst du oft so Rechnungen und sowas, ist das ein Problem, so Dinge, die mal anfallen, Stromkosten, hast du da mal Probleme? Ich wurde im Car2Go geblitzt. Oh ja, das ist mir auch schon passiert, ja. Aber ich hab's nicht genau verstanden, die haben ja gesagt, sie wollen mir eine 10 Euro Bearbeitungsgebühr zustecken. Sind das schon die Kosten für den Blitzer inklusive? Hast du schon die Post bekommen? Nein. Ja, dann warte auf die Post. Oh, 10 Euro, dann wollen die nur 10 Euro Bearbeitungsgebühr? Bei mir waren es insgesamt 15 Euro, glaube ich. Ich war auch nur irgendwie so zwei Kmh drüber. Wie lange wollen die denn? Road Rage! Ich war komplett außer Kontrolle. Florentin Gun Wild. Ja, nee. Aber ich habe letztens in dem Car2Go eine halbe Tafel Schokolade gefunden. Wo ich mir auch dachte so, ist das nett gemeint oder ist es
also... Warst du da schon der neue Florentin oder der
alte Florentin? Warst du schon Florentin 2.0?
Ich hab sie nicht verdrückt, ich war schon Florentin 2.0.
Möchtest du was erzählen? Aber ich weiß auch nicht,
ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich das gegessen hätte,
weil es ist einfach,
so Car2Go ist immer so eine
Staffelwelt, wo
so Staffeln gedacht wird und man nimmt irgendwie
so Storylines von der ersten
Staffel so auf teilweise manchmal.
Die Schoko-Storyline ist noch am Laufen
und dann kommst du rein, die neue Staffel und du hast dann
die Deutschlandfunk-Storyline schon seit
ein paar Folgen mittlerweile schon ein. Du hast noch diese
Handlungsstränge rumhängen und du denkst dir, ah, lass ich die
liegen, irgendwie sind wir jetzt hier so in Lost.
Wer hört Funkhaus Europa?
In jedem Kato-Gründer,
der sich einsteigt, läuft Funkhaus Europa laut aufgeräht auf, ich will nicht lügen, 85, Volume 85. Wer fährt denn mit so einem schönen Samba-Beat in die Stadt oder so einem schönen arabischen Klang? Finde ich toll, aber naja, Karthogor ist seltsam. Beim Drive Now musst du entscheiden am Anfang, musst du bewerten, wie dreckig das Auto ist.
Musst du früher auch, ja, macht's ja immer.
Und natürlich gebe ich immer schmutzig an. Nein. Klar. Du gibst immer sauber an. Nein. Ja, aber dann kriegt der vor dir Ärger. Es geht mir um mich. Ja, aber komm, nein, nein, nein, das ist ein Solidaritätsverhältnis. Was zum Teufel. Nein, das ist ein Solidaritätsverhältnis. Natürlich spielen alle im gleichen Team und alle sagen gut, natürlich. Nein, du bist so gut, glaube ich. Alle spielen so wie ich, weil du bist der Einzige, der an die Gemeinschaft denkt. Natürlich denken alle an sich. Normalerweise, du willst gut bewertet werden, du willst, ich weiß doch gar nicht, was passiert, wenn man dann Ärger, wenn man immer schlecht bewertet wird, keine Ahnung. Aber ich will doch, dass mein Zustand des Autos, den ich hinterlasse, möglichst positiv wirkt. Und indem ich den vor mir schlechter bewerte, wirkt es automatisch besser. Das ist wie das Gefangenendilemma. Du kriegst die Gruppe, kriegt das beste Ergebnis, wenn jeder nicht den egoistischen Weg... Beim Gefangenendilemma würden alle sterben, wenn ich mitmachen würde. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Du wirst alle in den Tod reisen. Klar, sofort. Nee, du musst auf jeden Fall solidarisch spielen, immer solidarisch spielen. Du musst immer davon ausgehen, dass jederzeit man sich den Rücken deckt. Dann bist du da gelackt, Meierte. Nee, noch nicht, noch nicht, wurde nicht gelackt. Ja, ich glaube, niemand wurde gelackt dabei. Na, ich glaube, es ist halt so, wenn jemand sagt, ja, hier liegt ein benutztes Kondom irgendwie im Auto, Hilfe, kann ich davon schwanger werden? Und dann sagen die, ja, Moment mal, wer war denn vor Ihnen? Stefan Tietze, der hat schon gesagt, das ist schmutzig, also muss es irgendwie Robert K. davor gewesen sein. Du meinst, ich habe jetzt 15 Kinder. Da wird Robert K. verhaftet, nur weil du gesnitcht hast. Ja, also da bin ich radikal und da will ich möglichst weg, wegkommen und ich will auch sogar, dass ich manchmal denke, ich hätte das Auto sauber gemacht. Stell dir mal vor, ich bewähre das schlecht und dann nach mir der sagt, wow, sehr gut hinterlassen, was glauben die, was in der Zwischenzeit passiert ist?
Dass ich dir kurz zur Tanke gefahren bin,
kurz schönen Staubsauger,
was glauben die, was da passiert ist?
Ich glaube, das ist der beste Mensch der Welt.
Der ist fünf Minuten gefahren. Der beste Mensch der Welt
ist der, der Car2Go sauber, auch so eine U-Bahn
oder so, stell dir vor, jemand so einen kleinen
Handstaubsauger macht dann irgendwie hinter sich sauber.
Arbeitet von euch jemand da draußen bei
DriveNow und kann mir sagen, ob ich als intern als der gelte, der die Auto sauber macht, der manchmal auch nur fünf Minuten mit dem Car-to-go fährt und plötzlich ist es sauber? Es muss aber Car-to-go Leute geben, die auf einem Skateboard mit einem Kanister Benzin durch die Gegend fahren, sausen, um dann zu den ganzen gestauneten Fahrzeugen zu kommen, die keinen Benzin mehr haben, muss sie dann halb voll tanken und dann zur nächsten Tankstelle fahren. Die muss es ja geben, diese Skateboard-Boys und Girls. Wo sind die? I want a skater boy, I'm next to you, me me me me me me me me me me me me Everloving, Everloving, son. Grossartig. Ich bin am Wochenende mit dem Auto gefahren und dann war ich in so einer ländlichen Gegend, so einer bergigen Gegend für Skifahren. Und in einer bergigen Gegend, da waren plötzlich so Schilder, die hat man schon mal gesehen, diese Achtungsschilder, wo eine Felswand ist und Felsbrocken, die runterfahren. Achtung, hier können Felsbrocken runterfahren. Ne, keine Kuchen. Felsbrocken, die hier runterfallen. Was macht man denn, wenn das passiert? Also worauf genau soll ich aufpassen? Weil da steht auch, da steht auch, bitte fahren Sie 70. Das ist ja auch eine Richtgeschwindigkeit, man sollte ja auch nicht langsamer fahren. Also ich fahre 70 und dann kommt dieses Schild. Wie soll ich darauf reagieren? Das Einzige, was mich bei mir ändert, wenn ich diese Steinschlagschilder sehe, ist, dass rechts oben bei mir so ein Highscore eingeblendet wird, so eine Punktezahl, und ich dann einfach den ganzen Stein ausweichen muss, wie Crash Bandicoot oder so, der halt einfach bereit ist, so jetzt geht der Level los, jetzt musst du ausweichen. Mein peripherisches Sehen ist so ein bisschen auf Alarm gestellt in der Ecke. Du guckst die ganze Zeit nach oben. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen rot eingekreist im Gehirn und ich habe immer so ein bisschen Angst, dass da was passiert. Aber was soll man denn da machen? Du bist einfach tot, auch wenn du das Warnschild vorher gesehen hast. Was waren die denn da? Ich glaube, man soll auf Steine, die auf der Straße schon liegen, achten. Aber dann macht man doch ein Steinsymbol und keine Achtung, die fallen die ganze Zeit. Auch die Grösse dieser Steine ist unverhältnismäßig. Das sind felsengroß. So riesenfelsene Hinkelsteine. Ja, teilweise gibt es ja auch im Berchtesgaden zum Beispiel so sehr bergigen Gegenden, gibt es auch so große Netze, die dann so an die Bergwände angebracht werden, wo teilweise wirkliche Trümmer drin liegen, wo du denkst, okay, das wäre jetzt einfach der Schulbus, wäre halt einfach vernichtet geworden, wäre der raufgefallen. Also die hängen da so über dir und denkst dir einfach, der Tod ruht über dir, lauert. Zwischen den Todweilen Netz. Und dann fährst du und das Netz hört auf, aber der Berg ist genau derselbe und denkst dir, oh, okay. Alles klar, ich fahre noch ein bisschen schneller. Ja, das hat mich gewundert, was soll man denn da machen? Das ist doch, weil Straßenschilder, die geben immer einen pragmatischen Ansatz, wie man gerade seine Situation sicherer und besser machen kann. Naja, dachte ich auch. Bis zu diesem Schild. Bis ich durch die Theorieprüfung durchgefallen bin bei meiner Führerscheinprüfung. Wo haben wir das mal erzählt? Weil ich nicht wusste, was diese Warnhinweise auf Autos bedeuten. Es gibt nämlich, glaube ich, A, B, C. Und F. Ich glaube, A, B, C oder irgendwie noch so ein Kram. Und dann war irgendwie so, wofür steht ein A? Und dann hieß es ja, Abfalltransport, Atomaresgut oder irgendwie Achtung, Neger am Steuer oder irgendwie sowas. Und ich habe halt gesagt, ja gut, das Einz was halbwegs Sinn ergibt, ist atomare Inhalte, so von wegen,
Alter, wenn du das lesen kannst, hau
ab oder so, oder pass auf, dass du nicht
mutierst oder pass jetzt auf, dass du keine
Spinnen küsst oder so gerade.
Nein, es ist Abfall. Und ich denke so,
ja, scheißegal, ob das Abfall oder
Snickers transportiert. Geht nicht, niemals
mit Logik an Fahrschulprüfungsfragen.
Das ist kompletter Bullshit.
Und bei mir war es so, ich habe die Prüfung gemacht, wir hatten dann schon an den Rechnern, saßen wir schon, und dann habe ich da gesessen und durch ein Zufallsprinzip, da gibt es irgendwie 12.000 Fragen oder sowas, die leicht abgeändert immer sind, und du kriegst durch das Zufallsprinzip Fragen zugeordnet, 30 oder sowas. Du darfst 11 Fehlerpunkte nicht haben, du darfst 10 maximal haben. Ich wusste, okay, ich habe zwei mit drei Punkten und eine mit vier Punkten, habe ich definitiv falsch beantwortet. Das weiß ich, die sind unabrückwärts falsch. Wird auch schon angezeigt. So, ich habe zehn Fehlerpunkte und ich hätte noch ein paar Fragen. Und dann kam eine Frage, die ich nicht wusste. Und das war die Frage, wie viel Liter Wasser braucht man, um einen Tropfen Öl zu verdünnen? Erstmal, ich bin jetzt seit ein paar Jahren Autofahrer und es kam noch nicht vor, das Problem. Dann habe ich da aber gesessen und wusste nicht genau, was soll ich jetzt machen. Gut, ich habe eine 33-Prozentige Chance, dass ich richtig beantworte. Ist sehr gering, weil es kostet ja auch Geld, so eine Prüfung. Ich gucke da nach links und plötzlich, habe ich glaube ich mal erzählt die Geschichte, gucke ich nach links und da hat jemand genau die gleiche Frage. Und es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, die Chancen sind 12.000 zu 1. Er hat diese Fragen plötzlich, genau die gleiche, weiß es auch offensichtlich, dieses Gesicht, ich weiß es sofort, klickt auf weiter und ist durch. Und dann habe ich auch einfach abgeguckt und habe das so angeklickt. Aber das ist ja kein Abgucken mehr, das ist einfach nur das größte Glück der Welt. Ich fände es auch so gut, wenn du so klickst und es richtig und so, yes Yes! Okay, komm, die nächste. Ich wusste es war. Du hast so ein Glücksspielautomaten, einfach so komm, einer geht noch, yes! Also völlig fern. Sie waren laut und durchgefallen. Am Ende so, ja, der hat bestanden, aber er kennt sich bestimmt gut aus. Ende vom Lied mit zehn Fehlerpunkten noch bestanden. Aber jetzt hast du im Nebensatz so was erwähnt, worauf ich noch gerne eingehen möchte. Du warst Skifahrer. Ich war. Der Titzmeister auf Skien. Ich hab zu mir gedacht, was wäre jetzt, wenn mich jemand sieht, der vielleicht das Podcast so verhört oder gute Arbeit sieht. Ihr kennt mich an meiner bunten, roten Jacke, die noch über war. Schneehose oder die klassischen Jeans-Skifahrer? Nee, schon richtige Skihose. Schwarze Skihose, bunte, auffallend bunter Kugelblitzjacke, Helm auf, natürlich Helm auf, ich gehe kein Risiko ein. Klar, so. Und dann habe ich so eine Skibrille, unter der ich meine eigentliche Brille trage. Toll, sieht wahnsinnig toll aus. und ich habe ich eine skibrille unter der ich meine eigentliche brille trage toll sieht wahnsinnig toll aus und ich habe einen stil naja sagen wir so ich kann mithalten mit leuten die schon sehr lange fahren weil ich schnell fahr ich fahre rasant ich kenne nichts ab keine ich sause durch die berge mit caracho aber ich habe einen grausamen Stil also weil mein Oberkörper ist auch zu groß zum Skifahren heißt es nicht immer so sehr weit auseinander, weil die sehr lang sind. Das heißt, meine Skier haben immer so ein bisschen eigene Situation am Laufen. Sie haben eigene Probleme auch. Der eine ist auf einer Anhöhe gefahren, der andere Skier ist im Wald. Die haben andere Probleme gerade. Verschiedene Probleme für verschiedene Skier. Leider für für eine Person. Und ich muss damit nicht mehr klarkommen,
aber ich kann ganz gut mithalten
mit Leuten, die ich länger fahren, aber halt
mit einem furchtbaren Stil.
Es heißt, man muss in die Knie gehen und dann ist
mein Oberkörper, weiß aber nicht genau, was er machen soll.
Er ist nach vorne und dann ist mein Oberkörper auch
nicht gleich, wenn er nach vorne ist, auch gleich so ein bisschen krumm,
weil ich halt so groß bin. Das ist alles
schwierig und dann fahre ich nicht so
schön, leider einfach. Aber macht Spaß. Und Stockeinsatz? Klar. Ja? Klar. Weil das ist immer so Anfänger, die anderen Stöcke einfach dabei. Ja. Also eher so als Ballast. Wir haben auch gelernt, ohne Stöcke zu fahren am Anfang. Das war das Erste, was wir machen. Und seitdem denke ich mir, ja, euch brauche ich nicht, die sind jetzt da. Ja. Die sind cool, um die Bindung aufzumachen. Oder so wie bei Ben Hur, dann irgendwie die anderen abzudrängen von der Piste. Das ist immer ganz gut, ja. Und dann war vor mir jemand im Lift, hat sich angestellt und hat gesagt, nee, hinter mir war so ein Mädchen, und die kam dann zu mir und hat gesagt, lässt du mich vor, ich bin YouTuberin. Wirklich? Ja. Und da habe ich kurz überlegt, lass ich dir das jetzt vor? Ist das so ein Ding, was man jetzt sagt plötzlich? Das ist dein Ernst, war das eine Bekannte daran? Keine Ahnung, ich kenne die aber auch alle nicht. Boah, schätzungsweise 19 bis 21 Jahre alt, kleiner, ein bisschen blonder und nicht wie wie. Nein, die kenne ich. Fiepsige Stimme und hat gesagt, ja, kann nicht vor, ich bin YouTuberin. Da habe ich gesagt, nein, nee. Müsst du vielleicht mal recherchieren, mal kurze Rechercheaufgabe da an die Podcast-Ufo, die PU-Army. Welche YouTuberin könnte das gewesen sein, die vor wie vielen Tagen letztes Wochenende? Letztes Wochenende in Winterberg. In Winterberg Skifahren war. Die hat wahrscheinlich einen Vlog gemacht. Vielleicht ist in diesem Vlog irgendwo auf der Piste. der hat Stefan Tietze gefilmt. Stefan, der sagt, der lässt mich nicht vorbei. Oder wenn sie irgendwie so im Lift sich selber filmt, im Hintergrund, findet mal diesen Vlog und schaut mal, ob ihr Stefan Tietze den roten Blitz findet. Der roten Kugelblitz. Ich bin noch lange hinterher gefahren, wütend, nach diesem Satz. Ich glaube, ich könnte dann wirklich drauf sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Gruppe vorhat. Aber das ist ja mehr gut. Lass mich vor, ich bin YouTuberin. Was ist das für ein Satz? Ich gehe auch nicht rum und sage, lass mich vor, ich bin Feuerwehrmann. Mastermind, ja, Comedy Mastermind. Lassen Sie mich vor, ich bin Arzt. Alles Sinn, leider einfach. Comedy Mastermind. Oh, sorry. Das ist schon ganz geil eigentlich. Ja, aber man ist auch so ein bisschen perplex und will so, weil niemand fragt, ob er vor kann, wenn er nicht wirklich einen guten Grund hat eigentlich. Das ist eine unübliche Kombination an Sätzen. Lassen Sie mich vor, ich bin eigentlich was Unwichtiges für das Vorkommen. Aber stimmt, heutzutage kann man das ja alles filmen. Das war früher, als ich noch viel Ski gefahren bin, immer mein Traum, so eine Skifahrt zu filmen. Irgendwann hatte ich mein Handy mit einer Kamerafunktion und habe das dann auch gefilmt und dachte mir, ich bin extra so wahnsinnig schnell gefahren, so schnell ich konnte, irgendwie durch die Waldstrecke so links, rechts, hin und her und habe mir das im Nachhinein angeschaut und es sieht so langweilig aus, einfach sieht so lame aus, so mega, als würde das mega aufregend, ist es nicht, überhaupt nicht und es war so enttäuschend, weil ich mir immer bei jeder Strecke vorgestellt habe, woher ich das filmen könnte.
Aber du kannst mit Gutschef fahren, ne? Ich bin auf dem Ziel gefahren.
Ja, ich bin irgendwann auch auf Snowblades umgestiegen, weil die Technik zu anspruchsvoll war. Aber da habe ich dann auch ein paar gute Tricks hingelegt. Also 360 war dabei, Darkslide und so war alles drin. Und dann halt auch irgendwie schön Bohemian-like hier auf dem Ohr, irgendwie schön diehemian like you auf dem ohr irgendwie schön die piste aber war ja früher ich will jetzt nicht in früher diskussionen aber gar nicht so einfach solche songs a zu finden ja und b irgendwie auch seine eigene geräte zu bringen bei uns war es einfach bei uns gab es schon mp3 player als ich mich für die musik interessiert ich hatte irgendwann meinen ersten ersten MP3-Player bei der iPod Shuffle ohne Display,
wo du ein einziges Album drauf traben konntest, glaube ich, 20 Songs.
Ah, ich glaube mehr.
Und dann hattest du, nee, nee, nee, auf den ersten, glaube ich,
du hattest wirklich 100 Megabyte oder so oder irgendwie sowas in der Ecke
und halt irgendwie so 20 oder 50 Songs oder so,
aber halt dann, du hattest auch nur entweder Shuffle-Mode oder der Reihe nach Mode,
aber keine Playlist oder sowas und einfach nur alle Songs hier drauf waren. Da habe ich auch mal einen Urlaub lang nur den Soundtrack von Die Fabel auf der Welt der Amelie gehört. Ununterbrochen, konstant. Hoch und runter, weil ich sonst nichts anderes hatte. Oh Gott, ey. Das ist furchtbar. Und was ist das? Das ist der einzige Hit da drauf. Was ist denn noch auf dem Album? Ach, ganz tolle Sagen. Schöner Walzer, schöner Walzer von Amelie und schöner Chanson von Amelie und was macht Amelie jetzt, Teil zwei. Oh nein, Amelie, geh nicht in den Supermarkt. Amelie an der Flöte und halt einfach die ganzen, ist ein toller Song. Amelie lernt Blockflöte, oh, den mag ich nicht. So. Ja. Ey, du hast auch viel Soundtrack, ne? Ich liebe Soundtrack. Ich liebe Soundtrack. Ich habe früher, als ich noch keine Ahnung von Musik hatte, viel Soundtrack gehört. Aber mittlerweile bin ich da eigentlich komplett weg davon. Also gibt mir gar nichts mehr so. Manchmal dann so ein, zwei Songs, aber sonst gar nicht viel. Ja, du bist ja unter den 1% John-Williams-Hörern der Welt angekommen, laut Spotify. Von daher... Ich glaube, ich höre mehr John-Williams an als John-Williams. Das kann gut sein, ja. Glaubst du mal, das habe ich mir oft gefragt, dass du mal einen Film häufiger gesehen hast als der Regisseur? Weil Regisseure gucken den Film ja häufig, auch dann im ganzen Postproduktionsapparat, da gucken die einfach, die schneiden ja auch dann... Ja, ist halt schwer, die halt dann eine Szene irgendwie hundertmal. Ich meine einen Film in Länge, also wirklich den ganzen Film, auch den ganzen Screenings und die ganzen Q&As, die da sind. Also mein Rekord ist ja Fluch der Karibik 1 mit 13 Mal im Kino. Im Heimkino bestimmt noch 20 Mal. Warum hast du den so lange gesehen? Was ein guter Film ist. Da Da waren Ferienverfahren. 13 Mal ist eine exorbitante Menge. Ich habe den jeden Tag gesehen. Ich war jeden Tag im Kino, weil ich nichts zu tun hatte und mir dachte, heute noch mal Kino schön. Aber noch mal der gleiche Film. Jeden Tag. Jesus, aber. Ey, Flutek-Ribrik ist ein richtig geiler Film. Der ist ein guter Film. Teil 1. Super Film. Ihr könnt ja ausrechnen, wie alt ich damals war. Zwölf oder so wahrscheinlich, also 16 oder so, aber richtig guter Film.
Ja, ist auch ein guter Film, aber dass man den 13 mal gucken muss. Ich will auch den besten Film, den ich gesehen habe, den ich 13 mal nachher.
Doch, ich bin immer so ein Wiederholungsgucker. Ich schaue jedes Jahr die Herr der Ringe Trilogie, ich schaue jedes Jahr die Oceans Trilogie, ich schaue jedes Jahr mindestens einmal Seven, Donnie Darko schaue ich jedes Jahr seit Jahrzehnten schon, immer wieder.
Ich bin einfach ein Comfortfood-Gönner. Ich drück mir das rein. Ein Traditionalist. Ja. Traditionalisten sind nicht einzunehmen. Schädlich für die Gesellschaft. Ja, stimmt. Na ja, nee, aber ist richtig. Aber woher kommt das Skifahren? Also wie muss man sich, warst du da mit Kumpels irgendwie ein bisschen Paprika, ein bisschen auch Saufen da, ein bisschen irgendwie Kliwein noch reingedrückt und so. Abends für den Kasten, wie reingepfeffert. Die Nähe zu Winterberg ist dann doch ein Argument, man fährt da nicht so lange hin. Und Skifahren ist schon cool, macht schon Spaß, schön die Piste runterrodeln. Aber bin ich nicht so oft, wir waren damals in der Skifreizeit eine furchtbare Idee, mit Leuten, die gerade nicht in der Lage sind, auf sich selber auszupassen oder auf andere, nichts können, auch mit allen so tollpartig umgehen, mit einem Haufen von 14-Jähriger in die Skifreizeit zu fahren, als Schule, was eine blöde Idee. Es ist einfach so, es ist lebensmüde. Es ist lebensmüde. Jedes Mal gehen da zwei einfach drauf. Ja, und wir waren 20 Leute und es waren drei Lehrer dabei. Natürlich müssen so viele dabei sein, weil es ist
mördergefährlich. Und es ist ganz
ganz seltsam zu gucken,
wie das dann so ablief. Und dann sind auch
manche Mädchen sind einfach so lebensgefährlich
klippen, haben sie den
verfangen in so
süße Mädchen, die jetzt rumgefahren sind und plötzlich
oh! Und dann sind
sie einfach so von dem Tod,
12.000 Meter in der Tiefe, hängt noch so ein kleines Netz, hängen sie dann so drin. Und dann hat der Lehrer erstmal ein Handy rausgeholt, hat ein Foto gemacht. Oh, Hanna. Und dann hat er ein Foto gemacht und dann hat er ja geholfen erst. Ja. Und dann sind wir mit so schwarzen Pisten runtergefahren, die wirklich einfach einen furchtbaren Winkel haben. Also ganz schlimm. Du konntest auch nicht... Vereist wahrscheinlich. Ja, vereist und du konntest nicht den Boden, du konntest nicht den Grund sehen, wenn du an der Klippe standst, weil es so steig war. Oh ja, oh ja, oh ja. Ui, das war ganz schön heftig. Das war auch ganz schön weit oben, wirklich 3000 Meter oder sowas. Und dann sind ... Näh, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das stimmt. Das weiß ich nicht. Wie Selbstbewusstsein gerade in komplettes Unwissen umgeschwungen. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, das stimmt. Und dann sind alle gefahren aus der Gruppe und dann war war ich noch unser, das war ein cooler Lehrer, der hat uns auch mal sowas machen lassen, der hatte auch über seinem Helm noch so eine Mütze mit so zwei Hörner drauf gehabt, so ein Satan-Typ, aber das war ein cooler Sportlehrer, hey, und der hat uns dann runterfahren lassen und nacheinander sind alle ausgerutscht, ausgerutscht, ausgerutscht, alle sind zu langsam den Berg runtergerutscht, hab ich auch schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, TXV, und er ist dann hinterhergefahren, hat alle Stöcker eingesammelt, hat am Ende so ein grosser, einfach so ein Arme voller Stöcker und ist dann hinterhergefahren. Und über mir ist Rico, der dicke Rico, habe ich schon oft erzählt, wo alle Angst hatten, dass er der Amokläufer wird, und er ist dann so langsam runtergerutscht, auf mich zu, mit seinen Stöckern einfach so vorne raus, Und dann bin ich wirklich, dann habe ich ihn gesehen, wie er gekommen ist, ich wäre gestorben, bin dann hochgesprungen, jetzt habe ich abgesprungen vom Boden, abgestoßen und er ist unter mir hergerutscht und ich bin wieder gelandet. Und das war so, das war heftig. Und er rutschte runter in sein Tor. Scheiß auf Rico. Aber allen war Rico egal. Nein, Stefan! Im Skilager sind auch zwei fast gestorben, die so hart ineinander gefahren sind, dass der eine Schädel Basisbruch hatte, direkt ins Krankenhaus, und die andere war auch irgendwie down. Ich war einer der Freunde des Jungen, der im Krankenhaus war, und dann habe ich mich mit einer Freundin des Mädchens, die nicht im Krankenhaus war, der uns einigermaßen gut ging, unterhalten, und wir so, ja, ja, ja, geil, irgendwie, megagehauen und so, cool, krasser Typ und die Mädchen halt mit hochrotem Gesicht verheult und so, nein, hoffentlich, ihr geht's so schlecht und sie hat gesagt, es tut so weh und wir so, ja, geil, so was los mit euch, einfach so ganz klar, damals noch so ganz klar, Jungs so, Mädchen so, einfach ganz straight, einfach so, aber dann waren wir auch mal mit einer Gruppe später noch in Jugendjahren zusammen Skifahren, unter anderem mit dem Mädchen, das sich verliebt war zu der Zeit. Und dann waren wir Skifahren und dann haben wir danach irgendwie so Rast gemacht in so einem Restaurant oder so. Und dann hat dieses Mädchen, wollte diesen Streich machen, dass sie so diesen Salzstreuer aufdreht, sodass der Nächste dann das ganze Salz sich drüber streut. Und in dem Moment fand ich sie nicht mehr cool. Und dann dachte ich, was bist du eigentlich für ein Mensch, das ist nicht cool. Bei mir ist es wirklich so dann so. Das Essen ist ein ganz komisches Thema. Bei Essen hat er das gute Steak versalzen. Ich habe echt an die versalzene Currywurst gedacht und mir daran ist nichts schön, Annalena,s ist daran gut. Ich liebe dich nicht mehr.
Aus, vorbei!
Ich liebe das Steak.
Und das Steak rettet er es dahin, hat den Salzsteuer wieder zugedreht.
Und eine gute Tat vollbracht.
Steak getätselt.
Ich stelle mir gerade so vor, die Geschichte aus Sicht des Mädchens.
Oh nein, fuck, die Fette steht auf mich.
Was mache ich dagegen?
Was mache ich?
Ah, ich weiß was. Du musst irgendwas irgendwas Essen machen, damit sie dich hasst, auch wie sich einfach sie nennt, weil du die Fette hast, ja, mach einfach den Salzstreuer auf, damit sie dich hasst. Ja, aber heute, ich meine, ich bin Prankster, ich bin Gag, ich bin eine Gagmaschine, heute würde ich es mega feiern, ja, aber damals war ich, glaube ich, ein ganz anderer Mensch, wo ich dachte einfach so, das ist nicht cool, das ist gar nicht cool. Und deine langen Haaren, schau mir vor, das ist jetzt wirklich nicht so cool, Leute. Ja, vor allem auch so, als ob die das interessieren würde, ob ich sie mag oder nicht so und auch so, Annalena, ich finde es nicht cool, halt die Fresse, ihr wirft mich mit Mayonnaise-Päckchen und so. Oh nein, du fängstst ja alle auf und lächst die beruhigst einmal auf dem Boden.
Ich muss euch schützen, in meinem Körper seid ihr sicher.
Weil ich immer gerade so mit einem langen Haar sogar keinen Spaß verstehe.
Bei jedem Gag sofort, nee Leute, das ist gerade echt nicht so in Ordnung,
was ihr da macht. Das ist echt gerade nicht so cool.
Also mit Essen macht man schon mal per se keine Spaß,
aber mit einem anderen bitte auch nicht.
Also halt ein bisschen weiser. Ich glaube, ich war früher ganz anders so. Ja, ich auch, aber das ist normal. Es gibt so eine Lockdown-House-Folge, wo es darum geht, dass die Leute sich nicht verändern und er am Ende berecht behält und die ganze Folge sagt aus, Menschen verändern sich nicht, Menschen bleiben immer gleich, auch wenn sich so ein bisschen was zwischendurch ändert, Sprache, je nachdem, mit wem man abhängt. Aber eigentlich ist es die falsche Botschaft, Menschen verändern sich.
Ja, aber ich finde vor allem bei jungen Menschen, bei so Jugendlichen in der Pubertät, merkt man immer ganz stark, dass sie oft so gerade in so einer Phase drin sind und man sich denkt, so deren Persönlichkeit ändert sich monat, wöchentlich, ständig hin und her. Unser Prakti zum Beispiel, Schülerpraktikant, ganz süßer kleiner Junge, ich habe heute gekocht und ich wollte heute eigentlich einen Linsentopf machen, weil ich ein Vollidiot bin und habe das mit den Linsen überhaupt nicht auf die Reihe bekommen und habe mich dann kurzfristig noch für Reiseintopf entschieden. Und dann kam er so zu mir und so, ah, was kochst du? Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich wollte erst einen Linseneintopf machen, aber habe das nicht geschafft, das ist nämlich Reis. Und dann meinte er so, ja, das Leben ist voller unvorhergesehener Ereignisse. und ich gucke ihn so an und denke so, ja, das stimmt, alles klar. Wo ich mir dachte, der ist auch gerade in so einer Phase drin, sich ganz elaboriert ausdrücken und so die Welt gerade wahrnehmen. Wo ich mir denke, in zwei Wochen rennst du irgendwie My Little Pony hinterher. Wo ich mir dachte, so cool eigentlich, so eine flexible Persönlichkeit zu haben, wo man in der nächsten Woche ganz anders sein kann. Und man denkt, ja, der ist halt in der Pubertät halt Mettler und nächste Woche ist er irgendwie so Hochseilkünstler oder so, wie so Benjamin Bliemchen, der jede Woche einen anderen Job hat. Genau, wie man irgendwann in die Weihnachtszeit meine Tante mir erzählt hat, dass ich immer Zaubershows gemacht habe, zwischenzeitlich. Das kann ich mir immer gut vorstellen. Ich hatte eine Zaubershow dann immer, das ist allen Tieren auf die Nerven gegangen, weil ich immer, alle konnten nicht anfangen zu essen, so essen war schon längst da, im guten Restaurant und ich hatte
erstmal meinen Zauberkasten ausgebreitet und hab dann, sind mir die Dinge runtergefallen,
da musste ich wieder neu aufbauen und alle waren extrem genervt, aber war okay dann
die Zaubershow.
Und dann hatte ich danach die Woche eine Piratenphase, wo ich eine Piratenshow gemacht habe,
danach die Woche eine Jonglierphase, erst mit Bällen, dann hab ich so Keulen bekommen
tatsächlich und dann wollte ich Fackeln haben, da meine Eltern gesagt, nein, das wird nicht
passieren, dass du Fackeln hast. Und dann hab ich eine andere Phase gesucht, und das hält bis heute so ein bisschen an. Ich habe mich nicht so wirklich verändert. Du machst jetzt seit vier Jahren dasselbe. Du bist Star-Wars-Fan, kaufst Schwachsinn und schreibst Comedy. Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. So viel verändert sich nicht. Doch, schon eine Phase. Innerlich vielleicht. Ich habe auch mal eine Phase, wo ich denke, jetzt will ich was Seriöses schreiben. Dann habe ich wieder eine Phase, wo ich denke, jetzt will ich um die Stand-Up-Comedy machen und so. Ob man das dann durchzieht, aber man dreht sich zumindest das selber so ein bisschen ein. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, früher, ich habe einen prägenen Moment in meiner Comedy-Laufbahn. Als Kind war ich noch sehr klein, wie zehn oder so, und da habe ich mit meinem Cousin immer bei meiner Oma Späße gemacht. Und dann haben wir irgendwie, waren ganz viele Freunde meiner Oma irgendwie zu Besuch, irgendwie so Kaffeekranz, so 20 Leute da, riesroßes Event. Und dann dachten wir, jetzt machen wir was, mega geil. Und dann haben wir mich so verkleidet. Und wir fanden es allein schon so lustig, dass ich den Mantel eines Erwachsenen trage. So einen Hausmeister, grauen Kittel, habe ich getragen, der mir halt viel zu lang war. Und wir haben uns kaputt gelacht. Und da hatten wir so, boah, und wenn der eine Dose Cola in der Tasche hat. Und dann hatten wir die Dose Cola und so, boah, und wir haben uns kaputt gelacht und fanden es so lustig. Ey, das müssen wir den anderen zeigen, das müssen wir den anderen zeigen, und dann kam mein Cousin so und der meint so, hey, sorry, gerade mal ganz kurz, ey, Florentin ist gerade mega lustig, ey, guckt euch das mal an. Und dann komme ich so raus, so als kleiner Typ so und habe halt so einen Kittel an und eine Cola-Dose in der Tasche und alle so Jesus nichts und ich so ist das nicht lustig? Ich weiss es auch nicht so, ich weiss es auch nicht und ich weiss noch, wie das so richtig so und dann bin ich wieder gegangen und dachte mir so, das war echt nichts, ey, da muss ich echt nochmal dran feilen. Und seitdem feilte er dran. Ich hab die Kittel-Cola-Dosen-Nummer immer noch nicht so ganz geknackt. Der Sketch, den du letzte Woche vorgeschlagen hast, der Kittel-Cola-Dosen-Sketch war sehr nah dran, hat auch niemand drüber gelacht, aber das ist es durch. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Und irgendwann kommt der große Florentin-Will- Kittelsketch, und wenn der funktioniert, dann hörst du auch mit Comedy. Dann ist das Trauma gelöst, und ich hab die Urszene verdrängt, und dann zack, löst sich alles auf. Du hörst auch mit Comedy, machst nur noch seriösen Quatsch. Ja. Ja, das wäre doch grossartig. Ja. So könnte er Florentin Wilds Karriere beenden, glaube ich, dem er ihn dazu bringt, ihm diesen Sketch zu ermöglichen. Glaubst du, du könntest jedes Buch schreiben? Wenn jetzt jemand sagt, schreib ein Buch über Solarzellen, könntest du das, machst du das? Wie ich eigentlich auch reingemogelt habe, ist, ich habe den Stil von Böhmermann, von dem Böhmermann, äh, adaptiert. Ja. Beim Anfang war ich mit Gastbatzen und da hat der Produzent nochmal nachher zu mir gesagt, du hast den Stil erstaunlich gut kopiert und deswegen bist du eigentlich jetzt da, wo du bist. Ich glaube, ich bin ein guter, ich kann gute Stile kopieren, glaube ich. Aber das ist ja auch eine sehr wichtige Fähigkeit als Autor, als Staff-Writer, weil du im Grunde ja gerade als Leitermoderator nichts anderes machst, als die Stimme des Moderatoren zu imitieren. Aber es ist die Frage, ob der Inhalt dann immer der ist, den man so will. Ich finde es interessant, wenn jemand in deinem Stil schreiben würde. Wir haben uns letztens darüber überlegt, dass wenn jeder von uns vier, die für gute Arbeit schreiben, einen Sketch schreiben, ob man dann, wenn man die nicht kennt, rauslesen könnte, wer welchen, also Katja sofort, allein schon wegen der Rechtschreibfehler und weil jede jede Figur immer anders heißt, obwohl es immer dieselbe Figur ist. Und weil die erste Seite eine leere Seite ist. Ja, vier leere Seiten, dann erst mal drei Gifs und dann so, das habe ich jetzt nicht von Modern Family geklaut und dann und dann wäre die so, warum schreibst du das überhaupt hin? Sorry, ich habe keine Endpointe, ist mir nicht eingefallen, aber ich schieße immer das Skript. Ja, immer so, das Gute an diesem Sketch ist, dass er keine Pointe hat, Immer so negative Dinge positiv bekommen. Alles klein geschrieben, teilweise Sonderzeichen drin, ja, ja, Katja. Tarkan erkennt man keinen Gags drin, Florentin erkennt man daran, weil es so super weird ist, super originell, wow. Und bei mir ist, glaube ich, ist einfach ein guter, solider Sketch. Ein guter, solider Sketch. Handwerklich gut durchgemacht, kann man umsetzen. Langweilig gut. Ja, erwartbar gut. Genau die gute Pointe, die man erwartet. Das ist ja nicht. Das ist ja eine große Lüge. Das ist genauso, wenn man jetzt irgendwie so Spekulationen macht. Ich meine, wir müssen gar nicht über The Last Jedi reden, aber wenn man jetzt eine ganze Spekulation macht, wie es sein soll und wie es cool wäre, denke ich mir auch immer so, will man denn, dass seine Erwartungen erfüllt werden? Ja! Aber eigentlich ja nicht, weil das lesen wir zum Beispiel unter unseren Sketchen oft so, es wäre viel lustiger gewesen, wenn, wo ich mir denke so, willst du denn, dass wir deine Ideen übersetzen, weil du willst ja eigentlich genau gerade andere Ideen sehen. Was ist denn der Witz da? Was viele Filme heutzutage auch falsch machen, finde ich, ist nur meine blöde kleine Meinung, aber ist, glaube ich, dass die zu perfekt sein wollen und keine Edgyness mehr haben. Das Gute an La La Land zum Beispiel ist ja, dass der mal all in geht einfach und teilweise einfach auch cheesy ist und auch gewollt cheesy. Natürlich macht er das wieder mit so einem Augenzwinkern, aber das sind die Stellen, die nerven. Ich finde es geil, wenn man denkt, man könnte eine Parodie über diesen Film machen. Die besten Filme sind Filme, die parodiert wurden meiner Meinung nach. Und das sind Filme, die es ... Die einen eigenen Stil entwickelt haben. Die einen eigenen Stil entwickelt haben und dann hier und da einfach mal auch zu weit gegangen sind. Es gibt so furchtbare Szenen bei den alten Star-Wars-Filmen. Furchtbar cheesy Szenen, auch in den speziellen Elite-Scenes, die den Film komplett kaputt gemacht haben. Oh ja, schaut euch das mal an. Guckt euch mal die Elite-Scenes von Empire Strikes Back zum Beispiel an. Der originalen Star-Wars-Relizier. Alter. Unfassbar. Ja, und ich glaub mir auch, wir würden auch über Szenen, die jetzt noch drin sind, das gleiche sagen, wenn das die Liedezcenes wären. Das ist schwer zu sagen. Glaub ich aber auch. Und dann manchmal sind die einfach allgegangen, das ist so cool zu sehen einfach auch. Naja. Ja, wir freuen uns alle auf den neuen Star Wars Teil und werden natürlich berichten. Yes! Ganz besonders wird Antenne Alderan berichten, für uns hätte sie eingeladen. Ja, dann bis dahin viel Spaß und haut mal was raus und ich freue mich sehr, falls jemand tatsächlich das Vlog-Video finden würde. Oh, das wäre so gut. Von der YouTuberin, die ihren Ausflug in Winterberg mit Stefan gefunden hat. Natürlich, das ist doch ein Ereignis, was die zum Thema machen würden. Jemand hat gesagt, ich lasse dich nicht vor. Das ist doch sowas, da machen die zehn Videos drüber, oder nicht? Aber hast du sie dann erst vorgelassen oder nicht? Nein. Echt nicht? Nein. Dann standest du noch die ganze Zeit mit ihr in der Schlange. Mega unangenehm, mega unangenehm. Daft der. Klar, aber ich habe auch natürlich Dextererwirkung. Aber könnt ihr nicht zu zweit in den Lift gehen? Das will doch niemandem, die sowas. Nein, ich war mit meinen Leuten da, ich war mit meinen Leuten da. Ja, ja, ja. Die sind alle zusammen. Die komischerweise auf keiner Aufnahme zu sehen waren. Immer nur der rote Blitz alleine.
Glaubst du, dass der Kugelblitz alleine nach Winterberg fährt, sich da Skier anschnallt? Ehrlich jetzt? Das glaubst du von mir?
Ich glaube, ich würde lieber alleine, Stefan.
Ja, du willst alles lieber alleine machen. Du bist ein Alleinstiegender. Auch spannend.
Alles klar, und bis dahin noch viel Spaß mit anderen Podcasts. Haut rein, bis dann, macht's gut, tschau und wir heben ab.